Amnesty International says there's been
what it calls a shocking spike in
Israel's campaign of unlawful killings
of Palestinians in the occupied West
Bank the Rights group has documented
instances of Israeli forces using lethal
force with impunity and quote a chilling
disregard for Palestinian lives it's
investigated four cases between October
and November last year in which 20
Palestinians including seven children
were killed the report also found
Israeli forces prevented Palestinians
with life-threatening injuries from
receiving Medical Aid and attacked those
trying to help them including the First
Responders 2023 was the worst year for
Palestinians since un records began at
least 507 people were killed including
81 children 382 people at least have
been killed in the occupied West Bank
since the war on Gaza began and that
includes seven Palestinian prisoners
who've died in Israeli custody Amnesty
International is urging the
international criminal court to
investigate at Israel's killings ban is
a researcher on Israel and Palestine at
Amnesty International she's one of the
authors of that new report she's joining
us from rala in the occupied West Bank
very good to have you with us just tell
us first of all how you gathered the
evidence uh over the October and
November we inter we remotely
interviewed victims of these attacks in
addition to survivors to families of and
relatives of people who were killed by
Israeli forces we focused on specific
locations in tul Kim area in Jerusalem
in areas where there were obstruction of
medical assistance to people who were
injured we then gathered all the video
and audio Visual Evidence available on
these cases and our evidence lab team
analyzed geolocated and verifi these
pictures that we either found an open
source or received from the survivors
and you using these different interviews
with people and the evidence the Audio
Visual Evidence we found that these four
cases that we documented were emblematic
of a pattern that has been used by
Israeli forces which is to fire at
protest during raids at people who posed
absolutely no threat to isra Israeli
soldier or Israeli Border Police when
they were shot we H documented
systematic use of Le and unlawful force
during raids during attempts by Israeli
forces to break down and crack down on
protests including just in response to
Stone throwing in Star clear violation
of international human rights law which
demands that authorities should not use
excessive force against Palace people
who throw stones and we also H found
that Israeli forces systematically
blocked ambulances from reaching wounded
people and providing them with what
could have been life-saving treatment I
want to ask you more about that because
that's something that we have been
covering uh here at Al jazer as well
this increase in the number of targets
that are linked to uh medical Crews who
are trying to help people just give us
some of the details if you can of what
you've heard about the way that uh the
medical Crews going to to people's
assistance um have been targeted by
Israeli
forces so one of the people in to K told
us that just as his son was shot and he
was trying the father of Taha was trying
to provide him with assistance as soon
as he was trying to reach he was shot
though the person who was trying to help
his son was shot by Israeli forces and
then Taha was left and his father was
left to bleed we know that during raids
Israel forces lay Siege to the entire
area sometimes for hours even for days
block in ambulances from reaching
ambulances that try to reach at Great
risk especially the red Crescent
Community organization they are shot at
we interviewed one first aid provider in
Janine who was directly shot uh as she
tried to as she was in an ambulance and
this this is not new we have been
documenting these attacks against face
first aid providers
ambulances uh uh in the end in the West
Bank for many years but what we found is
that this year in particular and in
follow up in what's going on Gaza on
attacks on hospitals that there has been
this Spike and perhaps last week's um
raid on the iina hospital is an new
epics of Israel's complete disregard for
the protected status that hospitals are
supposed to enjoy I understand that you
want the international criminal court
Court to take some action against this
because of course the international
criminal court deals with prosecutions
against individuals how confident given
of course that about a couple of weeks
ago we saw that ruling from the
international court of justice with
regard to action that it says Israel
should take to prevent genocide in Gaza
where does your confidence lie now that
if you take this evidence to the ICC
something may
happen so we know that icj case that
South Africa filed against Israel
accusing Israel of committing genocide
in Gaza is a separate case but in the
case of the international criminal court
unfortunately we are now marking two
years since the case against Israel was
opened we know that jurisdiction was
acknowledged by the court and despite
this despite two years the international
criminal court has been incredibly slow
at actually investigating Israel 's
violation what we found out is that the
some of the acts committed by Israel and
we covered in our report amount to
willful killings and willfully
inflicting suffering on civilians and
these are war crimes in addition to the
wider context which is a partage which
is a crime against humanity and within
the jurisdiction of the criminal
international criminal court we do
believe that these cases whether in Gaza
or in the West Bank or Israel's apartate
system against all Palestinians are
really a lious test to the impartiality
objectivity and vacity of the
interational justice system as Israel's
Judiciary has failed investigate these
violations Buddha Hassan we appreciate
you being with us and Al thank you very
much indeed for your
time